british prime minister boris johnson's
authority to fight his country's record
coronavirus infections has suffered a
serious blow johnson's conservative
party suffered a crushing defeat in a
central england by-election the liberal
democrat party won that seat that has
been held by the conservatives for more
than a century the defeat is being seen
as a protest vote against johnson's
handling of coronavirus restrictions and
allegations that members of his
government did not respect their own
rules the u.k which had largely dropped
rules and restrictions is now debating
the best way forward as the omicron
variant looks to take over
church services replaced by the military
who are helping to administer booster
shots across the uk
over a teens are being encouraged to get
their third shot as soon as possible in
the fight against the new omicron
variant
there's enough supply but there's a
shortage of space museums are turning
into pop-up vaccine centers to ease the
demand on hospitals
it made sense to get it done as soon as
possible
it's really important for me to feel
comfortable seeing my family at
christmas
coronavirus cases are doubling every two
days thanks to omicron it's now the
dominant variant in london
daily cases are the highest they've been
since the start of the pandemic
the uk's chief medical advisor warned
lawmakers that this is just the
beginning what's the current r value
where we're going over the next next
couple of weeks the rate of increase is
going to be i think fairly uh fairly
impressive it is sensible for people to
cut down on work or other
interactions of people including
potentially social ones which are less
important to them so that they they
reduce their chances of catching covid
and indeed reduce their chances of
passing it on
but prime minister boris johnson has
other ideas
we're not saying uh that we want to
cancel stuff we're not locking stuff
down and the fastest route back to
normality is to get boosted
johnson is relying instead on masks and
vaccine and testing mandates
at larger events like football matches
they still allow
spectators you just need proof of
vaccination or a negative test
we'd eventually have to watch it at home
and that's
maybe not as good as coming into the
ground
introducing even these light
restrictions was no easy feat what
stalinist minds thought
the conservative party faces an internal
power struggle
some of johnson's own colleagues are
rebelling against him his authority
weakened by scandal
is the party over for you now prime
minister
even before thursday's by-election
defeat johnson's political room to act
was shrinking potentially worsening the
virus impact
the uk hospitalizations are slowly
increasing the only good news is that so
far death rates are not
i'm joined now from london by dw
correspondent charlotte chelsea pill
charlotte normally a by-election like
this wouldn't make headlines here but
why is this particular loss for the
conservative significant
well this is absolutely stunning for the
conservative party the party of prime
minister boris johnson just to really
put this
into context for you abby this is the
first time in almost 200 years than a
party that a party other than the
conservatives have won this seat this is
a very rural area and interestingly here
this is a brexit voting area and they
have just decided uh that the party that
brought them brexit the conservative
party of boris johnson is no longer for
them absolutely stunning results there
they overturned a majority of
over 20 nearly 23 000 seats that that
conservative lawmaker had prior to this
by-election stunning results there now
one of the reasons that it's being
looked at so closely not just here in
the uk but internationally as well is
that this is being viewed by a lot of
people as a referendum on the prime
minister boris johnson he has suffered a
number of scandals over the last few
weeks and many people are framing this
as a judgment on those scandals from the
british public indeed that is exactly
what the lawmaker from the opposition
lib dem party said when she won that
by-election take a listen
tonight the people of north shropshire
have spoken on behalf of the british
people they've said loudly and clearly
boris johnson the party is over
your government run on lies in bluster
will be held accountable it will be
scrutinized it will be challenged
and it can and will be defeated
our country is crying out for leadership
mr johnson you are no leader
tonight the people of north rupture have
said enough is enough
they have said that you are unfit to
lead and that they want to change
so you can hear there she said the party
of boris johnson can and will be
defeated and exactly those comments
after this stunning result that will be
listened to by members of the
conservative party fearing that perhaps
boris johnson isn't the electoral
winning ticket they once thought he was
and charlotte if he's not the electoral
winning ticket that he they once thought
he was is this the moment now that boris
johnson loses the support from within
his own party
well there have been rumblings of that
over the past few weeks as i say because
of this number of scandals that have
engulfed the conservative party just a
list a few uh the member of parliament
who stepped down triggering this
by-election stepped down because he was
found guilty of breaking lobbying laws
there have also been these allegations
that you and i have talked about abby
about uh conservative officials partying
when there were covert restrictions in
place the prime minister himself has
been
wrapped up in one of those allegations
of a gathering during a lockdown on top
of that the prime minister has seen
the biggest rebellion this week of his
premiership so far a hundred of his own
mps voted against him when new
restrictions were brought in brought in
uh for fighting covid so as you can see
there real real intense pressure on the
prime minister at the moment and that is
only building now the governments will
say that they need to get on with the
job but a number of conservative mps
will be wondering is prime minister
boris johnson the man to do it charlotte
before i let you go what does this mean
now for the pandemic outlook in the uk
we know that the omicron variant is
spreading quickly and as you said his
own uh
his own backbenchers went against the
measures that have now been implemented
how can he move forward here
well as i say the pr the prime minister
and uh spokespeople for the prime
minister will say this is exactly why he
needs to get on with the job because of
the pressure that the health service
particularly is under at the moment with
this surge in covert cases now as a
result of the omicron variant which is
now dominant here in london expected to
become dominant in the coming days uh
nationally there are fears that the
health service will be overwhelmed we're
hearing that there is going to be a
tidal wave of cases
the last two days have seen
record-breaking numbers that's crucial
context to this pressure that the prime
minister is facing dw correspondent
charlotte chelsea pill reporting from
london london thank you charlotte